Hopefully this is going to be stable
enough for now. If it keeps dropping,
I'll just end stream. But I think we
should be fine.
I wanted to do Right. I wanted to get
Let's see if it actually can figure
anything from that. I doubt it.
That'd be cool, but I doubt it.
Yeah, I actually I know the artist whose
work I want to link in.
Huh.
That's weird.
Well, lighting definitely just makes a
massive difference.
Um,
oh, wait. Soft.
I mean this definitely does control
to some extent the uh softness
like like
Okay. What's this one?
Oh, okay. So, this is actually
So, this is like high ambient.
Where's our other puffer?
Honestly feels like partially a um
a change in
the geometry. Now
the old one was a lot more like a
pineapple.
Okay. I think
are the eyes in like slightly the wrong
spot?
If I just like look at the angle here
like this. I need to be like here maybe
and like here.
The eyes are like slightly downcast, I
think.
Very small eye position difference.
Should I realistically be doing this?
No. But
I don't know, you kind of end up just
doing everything.
Uh,
color picker. Hang on. Let me get an
HTML color picker.
Do I not have one of these?
I used to know what color this was.
Still thinking about the net hack
results. Those are really cool.
Mess with the puffer fish a little bit
though.
I don't know. This is super just dumb
easy work. There will be a little bit of
code cleanup stuff I have to do
once I have something reasonable,
Oops.
This does not work, does it?
Still pretty dumb. It's quick though.
It's quick to fix in a loop.
And we can just mess with these
till I get something that looks half
decent.
And yes, I could just load this into
Unity, but I want to make sure that it
works on our stack.
Uh, okay.
A 1 A.
Okay, that's better,
right? 61 A1 A. That's better. Yeah,
that's way better.
As what trains? We're not training
anything right now, dude.
So, I don't think it was this.
Like, can I pull it up somehow?
I think I probably can just figure out
the exact colors used, can't I?
Don't I have it somewhere here?
I'm sure I do.
No, this has got to be in here
somewhere. No.
Seriously,
I can't find the damn object valve for
the original. We had it somewhere.
Uh, I know I had that. I'm trying to
think where I put it. Wouldn't I have
emailed that to myself?
I probably would have, right?
Or I would have put it in I would have
put it in a drive, but I would have been
lazy and put it in the wrong drive.
I probably would have Let's
try let's check.
Damn, that's crazy.
How do I screw that up, man?
Oh, wait. Don't I literally have it in
the I put it in the damn repo, didn't I?
See, I was actually smart. I just forgot
I was smart.
Hang on.
Yeah, I put it in the repo. That's what
I did. I put it in the place where you
can't possibly lose it.
Possible on net hack. autoload.
Oh yeah, I don't know what's wrong with
YouTube. Is it possible for it to
autoload checkpoints as it is training
and watch the progress of each
checkpoint?
Uh, I mean, we can do that pretty easily
just by like grabbing Yeah, grabbing any
of the checkpoint files. That's pretty
easy to do. Um, we I watched a couple
full runs of it at the start of this
stream, though. This stream kind of got
chopped up a bunch with disconnects.
I watched like two full rollouts and it
was really really good. It got to the
Luxe room on the first one and
uh died from like basically
complications of lyanthropy
and then on the second one it got really
far
um into the main dungeon and such. But
we figured out that we're giving it too
much gold reward. So, it was actually
just selling all of its armor and that's
why it was dying because it was having
uh too high AC at that level uh at that
point in the game.
Um, if you wanted to hook something up
to autoload, like if you want to train
our current thing, first of all, you can
just like build net hack and run like
the the fast mode demo and it'll show
you the latest policy that we trained.
But if you want to watch as it's
training for whatever reason, yeah, you
could hook that up pretty easily to the
existing demo. Just point it at the
checkpoint stir.
I sent that message 10 minutes ago on
YouTube.
Yeah,
YouTube's somewhat I don't know what's
wrong today.
Like honestly, everything's screwy. I'm
dropping most of my frames. I don't know
what's happening to my camera color. Um
it's disconnecting every so often. So
stuff is kind of just cursed today.
I don't know why.
There we go.
Which Michael is this, by the way? Is
this Net Hack Michael?
What would you work on if it wasn't RL?
Um, most of the things that I am
interested in working on, I think that
Arl is going to be probably the right
way to do them.
So, I don't really know.
I guess I'd work on the problems that I
would care about. H, you know, without
without the RL edge though, like without
having RL,
most of the other problems that I'm
interested in kind of just don't seem
doable.
Like there's all sorts of stuff in
material science and bio, but like the
typical workflow for those just suck.
like and that doesn't sound like a good
time trying to do it without this.
That's so annoying.
Sign in to access this tree.
I don't remember my sign in man.
Okay, this is
I think the right Count.
And I'm signing into this.
There's lots of stupid work to do right
now.
Oh, great. We have to get a security
code.
Why the [ __ ] did you make me give a
password if you were just going to ask
me for a security code? Huh?
What the hell's the point of that?
Okay,
UI just lags.
Please work.
Why?
I hate this man.
I I hate these tutorials. It's like, oh
yes, just click the button that says
solve the problem and then there's no
button.
I hate this.
I honestly I hate this so much. No, I
like No wonder I don't use any heavy
tools. They never [ __ ] work.
Oh, this is FPR. Long training run. Hook
it up TV.
Uh, you can you could set that up very
easily.
Yeah, this is just not finding the
stupid thing, huh?
I don't I honestly don't know what to do
about this because
I do sort of need to pull up the puffer
in the editor.
Maybe I can just have it find the colors
from this actually.
Actually, that's what I'll do.
So funny how it's literally faster to
have GPT look at a raw not human
readable file.
of screwing with this.
Let's just not ever have to open
I wouldn't just say Unity. Let's not
ever have to open a program this heavy
ever again would be nice.
Slightly beige.
Yeah. So, these colors
do not look the same at all.
All right.
Uh, give me a second. I'll be right back
as well. Well, I got to check one thing.
Okay, here is the
here is the plan.
I'm going to order myself some food
and when the food gets here in 20 some
odd minutes
that will be end of stream.
Not that I'm doing anything that crazy
in the first This
to the file wrong for the original look
and original render.
Hey, whatever. We'll just keep let's say
this could just be a render diff, right?
Like if it's like this or some weird
thing.
Actually, there's an there's a an end
where this is
already included.
It look beige.
Yeah, it could kind of be beige.
Yeah, the lighting just makes a big
difference.
Hey Jordan
policy to choose 98% Jad.
Ooh.
Wait, is that on the entire fight caves?
If so, I absolutely want a PR for that.
You know, we're getting very close to
our release where we're going to start
needing all these fancy benchmark ends.
Absolutely
want a PR for that.
Okay,
this is closer.
Oh yeah, this is it. Look, you see this?
If you bias this up, the yellowing goes
away.
So that's probably what it is.
Yeah.
Okay.
Put the colors. Let me just put Let me
check one other one last thing real
quick just to be sure.
Hey, Muffin. Oh, I owe you a PR review,
Muffin. I know. My bad.
I owe you a PR review. I just finished a
major client thing today.
So, I owe you a a PR review this week.
Got your env to the puffer
presumably that'll get um 5C is much
faster. It should be, you know, a minute
or maybe a minute and a half.
Um, so we paid an artist to do this
muffin. This is not me doing animations.
This is me just screwing around trying
to figure out how we can get the
lighting to look good enough in our like
very minimal environment setup so that
you can easily just include the puffer
with whatever you want. This is just
like a crappy random like hack together
prototype engine. It's really nice
actually. Raleigh is super good for
this. Um,
and then we'll get the lighting and
stuff to be better and then he'll look
really nice. I think it's pretty much
their thing is it's mainly just bad
lighting at the moment. And uh then we
will be good to go.
puff into M's.
Yeah. So, we're just going to
standardize that in 5 muffin
2D and 3D.
And it'll be like the simplest ever
possible thing for this level of
quality,
guaranteed.
Way better.
Right.
Okay. This is a little creepy
to fix that.
Much better. Good progress.
This is like starting to get kind of
close at least I'd say.
Oh, that's actually starting to capture
it, right? Like
It might be very slightly off, but that
matters a lot.
See?
Yeah. The eye position is very very
slightly off.
This might be something that we can
change with the model.
Oh yeah, the spikes as well.
1414,
I think. Wait, actually we can use this,
right?
If we just
ambient needs to go down,
it goes down until we get like
and then Phil.
No.
Uh, okay. I got like 10 minutes before
orders here.
Is it directional or something?
If I go up until
like here,
I think we probably can cuz it's one
object.
Way closer, man. This is way closer.
I do think we got we pretty much did get
the face right. This is camera
perspective, right? Like this is the
face looks too long from that
perspective. But if you look here, it's
pretty flat.
Like this is the right shape for a fish.
Actually, look here. If you zoom out
more, it's fine,
right? It's just this is the forced
perspective. Like now it looks long, but
actually it's not.
So, I think that we just have to like
this fix eyes, fix little colors. I
mean, it take a little bit more futzing
with, but it's pretty good overall.
I mean, this is just dumb, silly work,
right? I'm kind of tired today. I've had
a lot of stuff done already this
morning, so I figured this needs to be
done for the release anyways. We paid
quite a bit to get our puffer redone.
Lots of animations and stuff, and I want
them all to be nice and easy to use. And
also, we want to be able to um export
clips and videos and new gifts and stuff
with the puffer for 50. We'll make a
nice launch out of it.
I don't know. We'll post some like
stupid high number for training.
Ever wanted to train at 400 million SPS?
Now you can.
Oh no. I have pabytes of data, but I
only have one machine. However shall I
train on it? What's that? Pabytes of
data.
Well, I have great news for you. That's
exactly the core diet of puffer fish.
Just feed it right into Puffer Lib and
you will get a state-of-the-art
superhuman model.
How's that even possible? I don't know.
It's magic.
Ah, okay. So, it got me this eye nudge
thing
up.
Oh, that's [ __ ] awful, man.
What's that? A three minute run.
You really should be giving us exabytes
if you want it to be remotely a
challenge, you know.
All right, I got to go. Food is here.
I'm hungry. Lots of stuff today. I'll
mess with this a little bit this
evening. Might do this. Might just like
do this in chunks on the stream whenever
I'm kind of tired. This is just like an
easy task that needs to get done. Uh
thank you all for tuning in.
Some cool net hack results today. Uh
following some good clients news, which
is always good for Puffer. And if you
want to support our stuff for absolutely
free, Star the Puffer on GitHub really
helps us out.